yes there have been crowds of people
here all day to pay their respects to
those who
were lost now this vigil here is going
on for another hour
here you can see piles of flowers and
tributes
that really have just grown tremendously
throughout the day
this is all to honor the five cyclists
that were lost
this week the vigil started at 10 a.m
with an incredible
outpouring of love and support from the
local cycling community
at one point a group of cyclists rode
through the vigil silently
to honor those who died family friends
and community members then gathered to
place flowers
write down memories and support each
other local leaders in the cycling
community spoke about the impact this
has had on everyone
and how they're going to move forward
together i spoke to the stepdaughter of
michael murray who is one of the
cyclists that was killed
she tells me he started cycling about 10
years ago and it saved his life
i feel like it's tough for for everybody
you know
this is an amazing human um he had a
huge impact with his faith
his his recovery and sobriety and um
he was an awesome guy it was hard not to
like him you know so
i feel like right now we're just kind of
reminiscing on the time that we did have
with him and
just making sure that he knows how loved
he was
many friends and colleagues of the
victims were here to pay their respects
the owner of a local mobile bike repair
company says he spoke to aaron ray one
of the victims the night before the
crash
ray was a brand ambassador and is
remembered as being a leader in the
local cycling community and a top
athlete
she was a dynamo she's only about this
tall you know i'm only
five seven and she's probably about five
foot four
but fast as all can be anytime we do
events and we you know we sponsor the
triathlon events out here in vegas
she's always up on the top of the podium
she's a
top finisher all the time
to help support the families of the
victims breakaway cycling is collecting
donations
100 percent of the proceeds will go to
those families
to donate you can go to
lasvegascyclistmemorial.com
now back out here live the vigil will be
going on for about another hour if you'd
like to come
and pay your respects for those that
couldn't attend in person
there was a virtual vigil at 3 p.m we're
going to head out live now
to madison kimbrough with more on what
was said at that vigil
yeah and on to another event today
honoring the lives lost in thursday's
cyclist crash
take a look as you can really see and it
was held at red rock
now the vigil honoring the lives of the
five las vegas cyclists was held at
three this afternoon with several people
tuning in to watch
they made the vigil available on
facebook live and zoom for people
that wanted to attend but still stay
safe and keep their distance during this
pandemic
several speakers including the president
of red rock
spoke alongside family and friends and
family members of some of the cyclists
that lost their lives on thursday
57-year-old tom tryer had
friends and family that spoke most of
them described tom as someone
who loved to laugh and his wife donna
holding back tears
thanked everyone for their support it
would mean a lot to me
if you would all reach out to me and
share any stories about tom or pictures
or whatever
you're comfortable sharing it will help
me heal
if you leave here today with anything
please remember this those cyclists that
are out there riding
sharing the road with you you're
someone's husband
son sister loved one
please think about this as you speed by
them in your car
today has been a day filled with
remembrance as several gatherings went
on to honor the five lives lost
as of now we still don't know the status
of the three other people injured but we
do know
that they were airlifted to umc trauma
if you're interested in contributing to
the gofundme page that was set up for
all eight
cyclists we have a link up on our
website live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now